we've got amy poehler with us give it up
so in her show making it amy teams up
with her friend nick offerman to test
the crafting and building skills of
contestants
um in honor of that teamwork it's time
for me and amy to team up
for a game we call what's creeping up on
me
what's keeping up on me
[Music]
all right exciting it was amazing jessie
um so you seem like you'd be a great
teammate for like a game night am i
right
thank you very much and yes yes i am
thank you so much
well we're on the same team in this game
so here's how it works
um amy and i each have screens behind us
um we can't see what's in our own
screens
obviously so we'll give each other clues
about what's creeping up without saying
the name of the thing
uh we can pass if one is too hard if we
can correctly guess
ten things in two rounds the audience
will win a cool prize and if not
amy sucks i was good are you ready
are you ready yeah i'm ready okay here
we go wait you're gonna give me clues
first
okay so ready what's creeping up on you
yes okay
ready go okay it's not an octopus but
it's like that
um yes yeah um okay the next one
is um uh the opposite of god it's a bad
force oh satan um
yeah um oh um i host the golden globes
with her
um okay this is uh this is great
uh okay this is a primate um doing
something that people do every day
with their morning with their with their
coffee um
yes so it's a girl or what would wanting
to have a constitution what do you
think think smaller than a gorilla a
monkey a chimpanzee
oh yes and he and this okay we'll move
on next
okay this is you hop on to uh to go
around new york city
um subway you know the uh the the l
there's one more
underground she can't hear me i said
subway
okay okay so okay this is the um this is
the symbol for america
a bit of our flag the american flag
angle no wait have we moved on to the
next one we're still there's still
oh that means okay that we are done we
are telling you did i get right
how many did i get right i got six right
okay that means okay here i'm moving
over here
that means that we need to get four more
for the audience to win
are you ready i'm giving you clues are
you ready never been more ready
okay let's do this go oh they're in the
if they sing you they say to pee on
yourself if they're in the ocean
yes um i can't see who it is
that guy um i'm a liar liar uh uh
you're serious i couldn't think of that
thing you did oh this is also
um something in the grass like from the
garden of eden that that
okay and then this is i what is that
oh it's like kids like these things and
they're in sand in their rooms tiny
things and
lots of them crawl in there and they
build like an ant farm yep
okay that means everyone in the audience
is a big winner
all right everybody amy's show is all
about making crafts but crafting can
make you work up an appetite so you're
all getting
an emerald legacy costume
enjoy fresh homemade pasta at home in
just minutes plus it doubles as a juicer
and frozen dessert maker which is
awesome so you can make sorbet frozen
yogurt
and even gelato or possibly frozen
drinks just throwing it out there
uh thanks for playing amy we were
awesome and we should have a game night
anytime kelly i love you congratulations
thank you i love you so much everybody
y'all can see making it tonight on nbc
and streaming tomorrow on peacock
also check amy out in duncanville new
episodes air sundays on fox
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever